the number one way to keep our kids safe
is having armed police officers at the
door we know this shooter fired through
the door shattered the door with the gun
if there'd been a police officer there
the shooter could have been taken down
before a single child was killed every
single Democrat voted against my bill to
double the number of police officers on
campuses by the way the bill also
provided funding to enhance school
security to put in things like
bulletproof doors which she couldn't
have shot through here's the Democrats
view they don't want to stop these
crimes if you want to stop these crimes
you'd put cops there to stop these
crimes what they want to do is they want
to disarm you